das ist zu 100% controller also da habe
ich einen richtigen job gemacht mit
meinen 17 euro was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen bei dem zweiten video aus der
alex wie rich woche ja die ist doch
nicht mitbekommen haben gerade läuft die
wisch woche es kommt jeden tag ein bis
video mit einem neuen produkt das ich
auspacke bisschen review manchmal etwas
teurere ist manchmal ist etwas
günstigeres manchmal ist es so
mittelmäßig wie zum beispiel heute ich
habe ja schon gesagt ich habe einige
sachen bestellt und heute geht es ganz
schnell gesagt mal um einen playstation
4 controller der ist letzte woche
irgendwann angekommen so sieht das aus
ja habe ich auch durchgesehen und
wirklich direkt bestellt weil es mich
interessiert hat
ich spiele selber gerne playstation am
liebsten eigentlich fifa wobei ich das
auch nicht mehr so oft mache ich einfach
manchmal auch die zeit fehlt aber eine
playstation an sich finde ich cool ganz
wichtig direkt am anfang auch heute habt
ihr wieder die chance etwas zu gewinnen
und zwar einmal diesen controller das
ist halt das produkt um das ist heute
geht und den 100 euro gutschein den ich
dann jeweils immer noch oben drauf legen
schreibt einfach irgendein kommentar
abonniert diesen kanal sammlung für
abonnenten wie immer wenn ihr euch das
video gefällt gibt gern noch mal oben
dann würde ich sagen will aber gar nicht
lange und fangen direkt mal an ich bin
wirklich gespannt ich freue mich auch
schon auf das video was dann morgen
kommt weil so ein produkt habe ich
eigentlich noch nie gesehen ich wusste
gar nicht dass es so was wie gut also
das wichtigste ist erst mal den jetzt
auszupacken
ich würde sagen das machen wir ja
irgendwie habe ich hier folge roten
stellen heute die ich gerade zum ersten
mal tut auf jeden fall nicht wild leute
so sieht das ganze aus
dieses logo gefällt mir habe ich glaube
ich auch schon mal irgendwo gesehen
keine ahnung und hier steht halt ganz
stumpf game controller ich kann mir auch
vorstellen dass er sich wirklich gut
verkauft
ich meine er hat halt nur 17 euro
gekostet und wenn man gerne zockt sei es
jetzt am pc kann man sicherlich auch mit
dem computer verbinden oder an der
playstation ist es natürlich schon
verlockend gut so viel bisher
wir machen das mal auch erst mal
gespannt wie das aussieht
[Musik]
also verpackung ist leer
hier haben wir einmal die beschreibung
das was den am start wird der
beschreibung also viel drauf steht da
nicht kann direkt masse beschreibung
hier haben wir ein ladegerät ist ja
logisch dass ich sehr gut gebrauchen
kann weil mainz irgendwie nicht mehr
funktioniert und das hier ist der
controller
ich wollte das schon sagen wurde in
dieser verpackung war er sieht einem
originalen controller ja vor ähnlich
jetzt merken allerdings schon den
unterschied also wenn wir den so in der
hand hat ganz wichtig ich hole mal kurz
ein original controller also wenn man
das hier einmal so hinhält fake original
der fei controller erinnert mich von der
form her ein bisschen an den xbox
controller zumindest xbox 360 hatte ich
vor meiner playstation deswegen kann ich
jetzt mal so beurteilen aber wurde ich
muss sagen er liegt gut in der hand und
was mir auffällt bei vielen sachen die
ich auch durch bestelle ich bin ja
mittlerweile schon experte das merkt man
sofort dass es jetzt nicht unbedingt die
beste qualität ist das kann ich bei
diesem hier jetzt allerdings gar nicht
sagen wenn mir dann irgendwann die hand
geben würde und sagen würde das ist
schon richtig hochwertiger gaming
controller würde ich es vermutlich
glauben also erster eindruck ist echt
gut
allerdings kann der zweite eindruck ja
gleich umso mehr täuscht man wieder
ausprobieren bevor wir das allerdings
machen ihr kennt er mittlerweile schauen
uns den erst mal genauer angeschaut und
die rezension dann interessiert mich
einfach immer so wenn man hier oben
einfach mal ps4 controller eingibt kommt
jede menge wir haben ja auch wieder die
ladestationen die ich ja auch schon habe
die wirklich gut ist nicht steht
dahinter kann ich euch gleich mal zeigen
also die lädt gut auf blitzschnell auf
alles toppen und hier haben wir vom bild
her zumindest einen originalen
controller ja also das ganze für 16 euro
den hab ich nicht bestellt da wären
nicht mehr passend angekommen muss ich
mit expressversand ob so ein produkt
angekommen wäre was genau so aussieht
warte mal das ist das nur eine hülle das
haben jetzt gerade so aus als wäre das
hier nur eine hülle ist aber glaube ich
doch nur ein richtiger controller keine
ahnung ich habe mir allerdings dinge
bestellt der jetzt bei ok gras 25 euro
liegt ich habe noch für 17 euro bezahlt
kann ich euch gleich auch gerne zeigen
also von den bildern
sieht ja eigentlich so aus wie auch in
echt wobei was mich freut hier sind auch
die zeichen drauf wir haben hier das
dreieck im kreis und viereck ist ja hier
gar nicht abgebildet das ganze wird auch
sehr gut bewertet 108 bewertungen der
frage schreibt funktioniert sehr gut
katharina schreibt ich habe nicht mit
einer so schnell liefern berichtet mein
mann wird sich sicher freuen heute abend
ist eine überraschung ist ja nett von
der catharina riess oder eben eine
überraschung macht mit dem controller
hier funktioniert super danke für den
preis super muss noch ausprobiert werden
schneller da als angegeben
qualitätsprodukt okay manfred download
sagt also bis jetzt einen absolut guten
eindruck kann man halt wirklich sparen
wenn das teil jetzt gleich gut
funktioniert ich habe gerade eben
einfach weil es mir noch mal
interessiert hat geschaut was denn ein
originaler controller kostet und die
original controller liegen halt alle so
um die 60 euro wobei mir ist gerade
aufgefallen ist dass dieser hier dem
hier leider das ist der gast immer 40
euro das ist zu hundert prozent der
controller also da habe ich einen
richtigen schlappa gemacht mit meinen 17
euro da muss man mal immer leute wie die
armen menschen über den tisch gezogen
wurden mit 40 euro und ich habe in
meinen ohren bekommen also da freue ich
mich gerade sehr und ich würde sagen wir
test sind jetzt mal ich bin wirklich
gespannt
aber ich denke mal der weg gut
funktionieren also an die zocker unter
euch die noch ein controller brauchen
neben mir auf jeden fall teil am
gewinnspiel vielleicht schicke ich den
euch dazu ich habe dann meine
playstation stehen und da sehen wir uns
jetzt gleich steht jetzt erst mal kurz
daran mich würde mal interessieren ob
der jetzt hier reinpasst das wäre
natürlich geil
nein passt leider nicht hier rein und
müssen wir es anders lösen
das hier ist übrigens die adapter von
dem ich eben gesprochen habe der jetzt
glaube ich leuchtet also eigentlich
sollte der jetzt angehen wenn man hier
drauf drückt oder hier drauf weiß es
nicht
ja jetzt ist auch an
er bringt grün schon angemeldet der gail
also dass wegen leichter als gedacht
vibrierend aber auch sound kommt auch
raus ist es überhaupt bei den originalen
auch der fall könnte jetzt gar nicht so
sagen leute ich habe gerade die ganze
wohnung habe gesagt ich finde mein fifa
nicht mehr das ist einfach weg jetzt
muss ich mir diese dumme demo
runterladen damit ich wenigstens einmal
spielen kann weil ich sonst kein anderes
spiel hier in dieser wohnung und esther
hat verdammt lange das gleich hier da
kann man es sehen also fünf minuten geht
das schon so leute nach zehn jahren ist
das auch mal fertig also ich bin
wirklich immer noch selber begeistert
liegt super an der hand und führt sie
echte ja an wie hoch qualifizierter
playstation controller also ein bisschen
anders als das original
trotzdem gut eine weile doch nach oben
die auch immer wenn irgendwas lädt so
ganz oft hier auf iks drücken also egal
ich will mal kurz darauf
[Applaus]
also leute ich muss sagen wenn wir uns
diesen controller ist hier noch mal
anschauen
ich würde sagen wenn eure playstation
controller kaputt geht und ihr neuen
braucht kauft euch so ein der ist echt
gut also wenn ihr nicht so wert auf
original legt der ist nicht mal halb so
teuer alle knöpfe funktionen finde ich
sehr sehr gut und man hat auch das
gefühl dass sie gut funktionieren bei
diesem hier weiß ich nicht habe mich
nicht so ganz überzeugt
aber der westliche controller top also
wenn ideen haben wollt plus 100 euro
gutschein schreiben kommentar abonniert
man youtube kanal und wir sehen das
schon morgen wieder um 19 uhr
und da kann ich euch nur empfehlen
einzuschalten weil das video wird auch
cool ja macht's gut
haut rein und